Google Cloud updates it seems like
everyone is on a generative AI Journey
right now and if you're looking to chart
the best course of adoption and to
create real measurable business value
then check out the new personalized geni
Navigator a quick interactive assessment
dives into your AI maturity your
industry challenges and current business
operations to provide actual actionable
steps we've introduced a new virtual
lab-based training for security Command
Center mitigate threats and
vulnerabilities with security Command
Center and the best part there are no
security knowledge prerequisites which
really helps address that chronic
shortage of security talent and you can
go from start to skill badge in under 6
hours check it all out on the blog we'll
catch you next week for more